when they lead amjad abujos to rest they
had a problem
shot coming home after a day at work
he's now buried in Janine near his
teenage son who died just five months
before
the upsurge in violence here over the
last 18 months has meant too many deaths
not enough space
the old graveyard is now full
it was very hard when Waseem was killed
but my father is the Cornerstone of the
house
I wish he comes back
come a lot sooner than they expected
when we buried my father if you look at
the graveyard this whole section was
empty every time I come to visit there's
a new Grave new faces new mourners every
time our pain is renewed in 2021 14
people were killed in Janine in 2022
there was a surge in violence and 56
people died the year is just over
halfway through there's been a number of
Israeli incursions and the number of
people who've been killed here is now
64.
now just a short distance from here is a
new graveyard a place they worry will
fill up too soon worries which found a
home when they had to bury 11 people in
one day killed in the Israeli Army raid
at the beginning of July
under the circumstances the number of
those killed is unprecedented and we
expect more because the occupation has
no boundaries to kill they use
airstrikes shells you don't know who
will be hit even if they have a Target
every graveyard is a walk through
history these cities of the Dead tell a
story of lives of moments of outrage
and now in Janine they've started a new
page and the people here worry that
history will arrive too fast for too
many
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Janine in the
occupied West Bank